carrusel de las artes
[Música]
maría carolina piña
bienvenidos a nuestro programa carrusel
de las artes esta vez desde el festival
biarritz américa latina' hoy les
proponemos un programa especial con el
que llaman el fotógrafo de los
escritores latinoamericanos el argentino
daniel mordzinski
[Música]
el reconocido daniel mordzinski conversó
con nosotros sobre su larga trayectoria
de la mano de los grandes exponentes de
la literatura latinoamericana
una historia en fotos que continúa con
las nuevas generaciones y conoceremos
los principales premios de la trigésima
edición del festival de cine de biarritz
américa latina'
[Música]
en nuestro invitado de hoy en carrusel
de las artes es el fotógrafo argentino
daniel mordzinski a quien vemos daniel
estoy honradísima de que estés en
nuestro programa pues yo feliz de formar
parte de tu programa y además para
hablar de un proyecto que quiero tanto y
justamente estamos aquí enfrente de esta
exposición que tú preparaste para
biarritz son fotografías que has hecho
durante 30 años de escritores y
creadores latinoamericanos cómo te
sientes viendo todo este trabajo de
tantos años reunida en el mismo lugar
que estamos viviendo tiempos ásperos se
hace un año me hubieran preguntado cómo
soñaba mi primera exposición para la era
post co vida
hubiera sonrojado me hubiera sorprendido
pero en cualquier caso lo hubiera
imaginado
luminosa y muy cerca del mar así que
esta muestra en biarritz es ese sueño
que este festival que tanto quiero hizo
realidad es un trabajo de 42 años
recuerda que a borges le retraten buenos
aires en 1978 la posibilidad que me
brindaron era de contar estas estas más
de cuatro décadas en 62 fotografías y me
pareció un bonito desafío hay más de 20
fotografías que hice en esta misma
ciudad durante este maravilloso festival
como olvidar que aquí conocí a gabriel
garcía márquez que fue la primera vez
que lo retrata de las muchas que luego
tuve la fortuna de hacerlo y finalmente
también quise hacerle un guiño de ojo a
perú país invitado por supuesto que no
pude incluir a todos los escritores y
escritoras peruanas que he retratado
porque son más de 62 pero evidentemente
los invitados y algunos autores más
usted hablaba de gabriel garcía márquez
está también en varios vargas llosa los
noveles latinoamericanos pero también
otros autores mucho más jóvenes las
cubanas carla suárez wendy guerra la
venezolana karina saints borgo el
peruano santiago roncagliolo
para haber hecho toda esta trayectoria
entre la fotografía y la literatura
también tiene que usted ser un
apasionado de la literatura
absolutamente siempre sostengo y es
parte
intrínseca de mi trabajo que el humor
salva que el humor puede ser un remedio
y un bálsamo contra las cosas más
tristes y entonces también incluir
algunas fotos
respetuosamente divertidas no donde saco
al escritor de su pose de escritor y lo
hago a través de algo que para mí es muy
sencillo porque soy un gran lector que
es proponerle otra pose y esa nueva pose
tiene que ver con lo que escribe y yo
quisiera resaltar por ejemplo una foto
que me llamó mucho la atención en una
bañera una escritora muy conocida isabel
allende yo me imagino que en 42 años
d'angelo usted tiene muchísimas
anécdotas con los escritores
latinoamericanos
pues sí tengo
en realidad más que anécdotas tengo
mucha suerte mi gran fortuna es la gente
que conocí que retrate es la confianza
que me dan los escritores las escritoras
la foto isabel allende es la primera vez
que la comparto nunca lo había mostrado
es una foto inédita que hice justo antes
de que comience la pandemia me enteré
que isabel allende estaba en barcelona y
hablé con su agente con la agencia
balcells le propusieron este encuentro y
ella dijo claro que sí me tomé un tren
me fui a barcelona y entonces fue muy
hermoso porque yo intenté sin hablar de
mis libros o exposiciones contarle a
isabel que era mi trabajo y ella me
interrumpió y me dijo danielle yo tengo
no hace muchos años tenía muchos deseos
que me re trates a todos sí y claro
cuando isabel allende te hice a todos y
lo mínimo es vamos a la bañera
y así salió esa foto culpa de ella a
todos sí y hay otros encuentros que se
han convertido para ustedes que se
convirtieron para ustedes en una gran
amistad pienso especialmente luis
sepúlveda que nos dejó el año pasado y
yo creo que también esa foto para usted
era importante poner la cara
absolutamente sí louis se ocupa en mi
vida en mi corazón un lugar muy
importante me termine de romper el 16 de
abril cuando él falleció
yo estaba a su lado cuando se contagió
en portugal en el 24 de febrero nos
separamos por última vez y claro lo
primero es porque él se fue y yo me
quedé porque se enfermó y yo no me
contagié
louis ha sido testigo y cómplice de toda
mi vida profesional y claro no solamente
está luis sepúlveda sino a su lado está
carmen yáñez la gran poeta a la
compañera de toda su vida se me rompe la
voz para que aquí en la playa terminada
aquí que de repente tras el
profundo bello y emotivo homenaje que la
ciudad de biarritz y este festival le
hicieron a luís mira el mar y saluda
como diciéndole mucho que acabamos de
decir adiós ahí estás ahí dónde voy y yo
estaba con mi cámara hice dos clic y
evidentemente esa foto tenía que
dialogar con la otra imagen de louis en
patagonia bueno para recuperarnos de esa
anécdota que yo sé que es dolorosa para
usted le propongo que escuchemos la
opinión de una escritora que está acá
karina pacheco y que nos va a contar qué
es hacer una fotografía con daniel
morcillo
para mí fue como entrar en un juego en
un gran juego y a veces tengo la
sensación que daniel mordzinski sin
proponérselo estuviera creando digamos
ese mapa de la literatura que es un
objetivo claro pero que también
estuviera creando un enorme juego donde
todos participamos son los autores
autoras creadores participamos fue muy
lindo porque estábamos haciendo la ruta
del barroco andino que parte de cusco
por el valle sur en un viaje que
prosiguió hasta puno y arequipa y fuimos
a este lugar que es la casa del antiguo
marqués del valle umbroso y es un centro
de restauración de arte colonial
entonces sentía como que al hacerme esa
foto me estaba retratando en mi lugar
que es entre las montañas pero al mismo
tiempo en un sitio que habla del
presente
y del pasado entonces esa complicidad el
respeto y el juego que él te plantea al
proponerte una foto es algo hermoso y te
sientes
es revelada en todo el sentido de la
palabra
seguimos aquí en biarritz en compañía
del fotógrafo argentino daniel
mordzinski daniela wta vamos de
literatura de su pasión por la
literatura la fotografía y justamente
hace unos días el escritor sergio
ramírez a quien usted también ha
fotografiado y que también en su amigo
recibió una orden de detención por parte
del gobierno de nicaragua como vivió
usted ese momento porque es importante
para la literatura latinoamericana pues
lo recibí con indignación y con dolor
con tristeza
como una puñalada doble porque si hay un
autor que representa la ética la moral
en la vida en la escritura en la
política
sergio ramírez lo único que espero es
que su último libro
pueda romper las barreras de la censura
y de las injusticias y se ha leído en
cada hogar de nicaragua para que se haga
una justa revancha pues creo que la
palabra escrita del escritor es
muy importante y nadie puede pararla
espero que pronto se haga justicia y
sueño que próximamente podamos volver
todos a nicaragua y celebrar juntos
centroamérica cuenta porque
centroamérica porque nicaragua debe
seguir contando y con esas palabras a
daniel le agradezco por haber estado con
nosotros haber compartido esta larga
historia con el festival de biarritz y
con la literatura latinoamericana
muchísimas gracias gracias a ti y
simplemente quería agregar ojalá que
esta exposición y que este año puedan
contribuir a perennizar un festival tan
importante como el de biarritz
muchísimas gracias daniel y justamente
como este festival no es sólo de
literatura sino también hay una
competencia cinematográfica los invito a
que descubramos los principales premios
del festival biarritz américa latina'
pero lo soñaste o fue de verdad
las dos cosas una película argentina
triunfo en el festival biarritz américa
latina' jesús lópez de maximiliano
schonfeld se llevó el premio el abrazo
al mejor largometraje de ficción una
cinta filmada en la provincia de entre
ríos y que aborda el mundo del campo y
de los espíritus en las comunidades en
las que yo soy en entre ríos los los
fantasmagóricos está siempre presente
sobre todo en el campo con historias con
imágenes con luces y bueno jesús lópez
para mí la personificación de alguna
manera de eso de esa fantasía y de esos
miedos así que me alegro mucho de que
les haya gustado
república dominicana estuvo presente en
la competencia con dos películas y las
dos se llevaron galardones candela de
andrés farías galardonada con el premio
del jurado y una película sobre parejas
de natalia cabral y oriol estrada
distinguida con el premio de la crítica
y el premio de interpretación
ahora
como es trabajar en pareja
y uno se tiene miedo pero es una
película final nosotros actuamos y
ponemos nuestra vida y uno siempre
piensa bueno quizás eso no le interesa a
nadie y quizás no le interesa nada pero
de alguna manera los de los premios no
la gente nos comenta que la pasaron bien
que se rieron que reflexionaron entonces
es solo que mano llena también que al
público le haya gustado por su parte la
argentina que será del verano fue
galardonada con el premio al mejor
documental entregado por radio francia
internacional y france 24 mientras que
entre ellas una cinta sobre la condición
de las mujeres se llevó el premio al
mejor cortometraje con esta velada se
cerró la edición número 30 del festival
de risa américa latina que tuvo perú
como país invitado de honor como
para que sea
[Música]
ya nos toca despedir este programa
especial carrusel de las artes que les
presentamos desde el festival biarritz
américa latina y los dejamos con la
violinista cubana gillian cañizares una
de las artistas de la edición 2021 del
festival muchísimas gracias por su
sintonía y hasta la próxima jaua
toni al más limpio